ennio morricone le compositeur de plus
de 400 musique de film celle de par
exemple henri verneuil ou sert du rhône
à l'occasion de ses 40 ans de carrière
ennio morricone dirigera l'orchestré
symphonique de rome au palais des
congrès que le christ peau à béziers
l'harmonica d'il était une fois dans
l'ouest
aussitôt le nom d'ennio morricone
s'impose dans une production riche de
plus de 400 musique de film qui toutes
sont nés chez lui à rome dans ce lieu
secret le saint des saints ou même sa
femme de ménage ne pénètre jamais
tous les jours le maestro retrouve son
bureau
et quand les notes court sur la
partition dans sa tête la musique est
déjà créée que ce soit pour un film où
c'est moins connu pour une composition
contemporaine
bien sûr c'est un peu déplaisant que les
gens me connaissent ils me qu'ils
ignorent tout une partie de mon travail
de création plus personnel plus intime
en rapport avec une autre musique que
celle des films andré est le fils lui
aussi compositeur
même si au départ son père a essayé de
le dissuader ennio est particulièrement
fier de son travail
la preuve à 80 ils ont travaillé sur le
film cinéma paradiso
ennio n'enseigner andré a qu'une seule
recette pour réussir
j'ai travaillé toute une vie quand je
continue de le faire et c'est peut-être
la clé est la réponse à toutes les
questions sur ma réussite
c'était une vocation bien sûr je ne sens
pas la fatigue en travaillant dans le
monde
esneu compte des milliers de fans dont
laurent depuis 20 ans un intérêt jamais
démenti
il relie 3 3 critères que ok je suis
extrêmement sensible c'est à dire qu'il
est à l'inventivité la profondeur et
l'intensité
bien sûr laurent sera dans le public
pour l'unique concert parisien d'ennio
morricone être un florilège de ses
musiques de films